vamos con el problema 56 arturo está
construyendo una recta perpendicular a
la recta l l desde el punto p ok algo
más o menos de este estilo cuál de los
siguientes debe ser su primer paso a ver
vamos a ver qué está haciendo a quién a
tenemos esta tache de aquí y está tache
de acá pero esas taches no nos dicen
cómo se construyen ni nada están muy
misteriosas entonces aquí no tenemos
nada de información para construir la
recta perpendicular vale a ver ve en él
ve pues al parecer se marca un punto
aquí se marcó un punto acá y luego
tomamos tomamos el compás como centro
aquí y trazamos este arco y luego
trazamos similarmente este arco de acá
pero luego pues no tenemos mucha
información verdad o sea lo que nos
gustaría es bajar y bajar aquí una
perpendicular entonces a lo mejor nos
gustaría que éste fuera punto medio de
estos dos verdad como por simetría
pero aquí no tenemos nada de información
de estos dos o sea no sabemos cómo los
construimos así que pues quién sabe
entonces éste tampoco se ve prometedor
inciso c en el cs toma un punto aquí y
luego este arco pero eso es hacer menos
que acá no sea realmente este es este
arco de acá no sirve de nada más que
para encontrar este punto pero otra vez
no tenemos nada de información ni de
este punto ni de este punto entonces
pues quién sabe y ahora inciso d
entonces ésta tampoco pero inciso d el
inciso de sb que está un poco mejor
ahora lo que se hace es tomar un círculo
con centro en p abrirlo para acá ver
dónde corta la recta l y marcar esos dos
puntos eso ya se ve un poco mejor por lo
siguiente como esto de aquí es una
circunferencia entonces este segmento es
un radio este segmento también y por lo
tanto este de aquí es
estoy acá estos dos segmentos miden lo
mismo entonces si consiguiéramos otro
punto equidistante pudiéramos construir
la media triz y eso ya es sencillo lo
que podemos hacer es tomarnos dos
circunferencias digamos esa de allí y
esa de allá pero teniendo cuidado de no
cerrar el compás o sea que tengan el
mismo radio ba y ahora estas dos
circunferencias pues se cortan en un
punto por acá y resulta que la distancia
de este punto aquí es la misma que la de
este punto acá porque justo este es un
radio de esta que lo tomamos igual al
radio de la de acá que es esta longitud
entonces este segmento verde mide lo
mismo que este de acá y por lo tanto
ahora tenemos dos puntos en la media
triz de este segmento y por lo tanto al
unir p con este punto de acá obtenemos
una perpendicular y eso es justo lo que
queríamos verdad una perpendicular a l
que pasara por p muy bien entonces la
opción la respuesta es la opción de muy
bien problema 57
o el triángulo puede construirse
siguiendo estos pasos para esto se ve
interesante uno poner la punta del
compás en a aunque hay punta del compás
en al abrir el compás de modo que el
lápiz toque en vez que abrimos el compás
para acá déjame agarrar el compás bueno
es la herramienta de círculo pero bueno
funciona como compás 3 dibujar un arco
por encima del segmento ave o sea ese es
cargo de acá voy a hacer todo el círculo
algo de este estilo muy bien luego sin
cambiar la apertura esto se ve
importante sin cambiar la apertura poner
la punta en b y dibujar un arco que
intersecta el primero en un punto c por
supuesto este va a pasar por a verdad
porque no estamos cambiando la apertura
entonces más o menos algo de este estilo
entonces es éste esta circunferencia
pasa por ahí por esta circunferencia
pasa por pse y por ver y queremos ver
qué tipo de triángulo es éste bueno pues
como la primera es una circunferencia y
hace y aves son radios entonces miden lo
mismo ave es congruente con hace y de
manera similar como esta segunda es una
circunferencia
y ve a veces son radios entonces vean es
congruente a veces estos dos miden lo
mismo y por lo tanto construimos un
triángulo con sus tres lados iguales y
así es equilátero a ver a no no no de de
equilátero respuesta de muy bien
problema 58 bueno aquí está aquí se
cruzó un poquito en la construcción de
arriba pero no importa creo que no está
hecho nada no cruzo nada bueno
el diagrama muestra el triángulo abc
aquí tenemos el triángulo abc ok que
anunciado probaría que el triángulo abc
es rectángulo
rectángulo ok no sé o sea me imagino que
quieren que veamos que este este ángulo
de acá sea recto estos no se ven tan
rectos entonces vamos a intentar dar
condiciones para que el segmento ave sea
perpendicular al segmento bs y yo creo
que vamos a utilizar una propiedad que
se estudia en cursos de álgebra cuando
cuando se dibujan funciones cuando se
dibujan sobre todo líneas y esa
propiedad es que si una recta tiene
pendiente l y otra recta tiene pendiente
m y tenemos que esas dos son
perpendiculares entonces la pendiente m
es igual al inverso negativo de l es
igual a menos 1 entre l vale y bueno
justo queremos pensar cosas en términos
dependientes porque aquí hay opciones en
términos dependientes vamos a ver si
alguna de estas dice lo que queremos
queremos que la pendiente de ave sea el
inverso negativo de la pendiente bc a
ver que tenemos por acá bueno aquí las
multiplican bueno si m es igual a menos
1 entre l multiplicando por l de ambos
lados aquí se cancela nos queda que l m
igual a menos 1 algunas de éstas parece
ser si la b parece ser la correcta
verdad la pendiente de ave por la
pendiente de bc es igual a menos 1 que
la pendiente de ave por la pendiente de
bc de esos dos segmentos sea igual a
menos 1 si esto es justo lo que queremos
inciso b muy bien vamos al problema 59
dice la figura abc es un paralelogramo
ok me parece bien
esto es paralelo a este este es paralelo
a este de acá y además nos dan ahí
algunas coordenadas en el plano a quiché
y nos preguntan cuáles son las
coordenadas del punto de intersección de
sus diagonales diagonales ok
queremos las coordenadas de este punto
de acá creo que ya lo habíamos
mencionado pero bueno lo vuelvo a decir
la propiedad importante que vamos a
utilizar aquí es que las diagonales de
un paralelogramo se secan o sea se
cortan a la mitad a lo que me refiero es
que si este punto se llama digamos d
entonces o de mí de lo mismo que debe
son segmentos congruentes y ade mide lo
mismo que desee también son segmentos
congruentes y con esto ya podemos tener
información de las coordenadas de de por
qué pues podemos pensarlo como como el
punto medio de uve y entonces
simplemente hay que promediar las
coordenadas del origen con ve como
hacemos eso pues promediamos coordenada
coordenada entonces las coordenadas nos
quedarían los que nos quedarían a más y
más cero porque cero es la coordenada en
x del origen dividido entre 2,20 b más 0
dividido entre 2 va y si lo piensas
tiene mucho sentido se realmente la
coordenada en x de éste pues debería
quedar a la mitad de la coordenada en x
de acá porque porque porque el otro
punto está en el origen entonces si
estoy acá está más este de acá debería
ser más entre 2 y de manera similar la
altura la altura de acá debe ser la
mitad de esta altura esta altura es ve
como como estamos promediando con el
origen
debería quedar aquí de entre dos vale
por eso promediamos coordenada
coordenada bueno entonces que nos
quedaría sería a más de entre 2
como ve entre dos ve entre dos a ver
esta es la opción c la opción c muy bien
y finalmente para este vídeo vamos a
hacer el problema 60 dice qué tipo de
triángulo es uno con coordenadas y nos
dan ciertas coordenadas bueno creo que
lo ideal aquí es hacer un dibujo poner
poner este un plano aquí y hacer un
esbozo de lo que nos dan y más o menos
de ahí pensar que queremos mostrar vale
bueno entonces que una un vértice es el
vértice que tiene coordenadas 42
entonces vamos a marcar uno dos tres
cuatro y aquí arriba 12 entonces aquí
está el vértice a más o menos
luego el vértice b tiene coordenadas 6 -
1 1 2 3 4 5 6 coma menos 1 entonces está
más o menos por acá b y finalmente el
vértice se tiene coordenadas menos 1
3123 entonces está por aquí
excelente entonces déjame déjame hacer
el triángulo en color naranja voy a unir
este con este este con este y este con
este ahora así a simple vista
bc es mucho más grande que cualquiera de
los otros dos lados y hace le gana a ave
entonces parece ser que es un triángulo
escaleno los tres lados son diferentes
entonces yo diría que d pero para
asegurarnos pues vamos a verificar pues
basta verificar ave contra hace las
longitudes de esos segmentos como que la
otra ya es muy grande bueno entonces
queremos encontrar cuánto mide ave y
para encontrar eso para encontrar la
medida de ave
la medida del segmento ave lo que
tenemos que hacer es utilizar el teorema
de pitágoras la medida de ave al
cuadrado es igual a la diferencia de las
coordenadas en x de estos puntos al
cuadrado que sería que 6 menos 4 al
cuadrado o sea este 2 al cuadrado más la
diferencia de las coordenadas en que
sería 2 menos menos 12 - menos 1 estrés
entonces 2 al cuadrado más 3 al cuadrado
que estoy aquí es igual a 4 más 9
que es igual a 13 y por lo tanto ave
mediría a raíz de 3 y ahora vamos a ver
cuál es la longitud hace cuánto mide el
segmento hace de manera similar a ver
tenemos que que ponerle aquí hace al
cuadrado es igual a la resta de las
coordenadas en x o sea 4 menos menos 15
al cuadrado más la resta de las
coordenadas en 3 menos 2 o 2 menos tres
es lo mismo 1 o menos 1 que al cuadrado
nos da 1 entonces sería 5 al cuadrado
más 1 al cuadrado y entonces nos queda
25 más 1 que es igual a 26 y entonces
hace mide 26 26 raíz de 26 verdad porque
hace al cuadrado es 26 entonces ave y
hace son distintos y por lo tanto
tenemos que abc es un triángulo escaleno
muy bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo para
continuar con el 61